so has he made you change any diapers
yet we are so excited to be able to
recommend Jackson for this reading
program so if you just want to go home
and talk it over with your husband let
us know I mean I can let you know now I
think it would be a great idea uh I mean
it's okay you can you can go home and
talk it over so you're staying home on
now yeah and you're totally okay with
your husband being the one who brings
home the bacon oh look at you pitching
in doing laundry so helpful oh sorry
there's no changing table in the women's
restroom there isn't no you can try
across the street though hi she looks
great
thank you did dad get her dressed but
you can't wait to get back to work Oh
looks like someone got stuck babysitting
this weekend well I'm not getting paid
so I think it's just parenting don't let
your girlfriend see you acting like this
hi hi there reason you're at the
playground today yeah here's my kid
which one boom right over there in the
no fear shirt his name Jackson hey
Jackson just your mom are you okay did
you get Ellie oh you see gonna give it a
kiss I'll go get your husband okay
I'll get him up here in just a second
they always want their daddy yeah